33 neue corona fälle gibt es jetzt
nämlich in garmisch partenkirchen eine
26-jährige soll schuld an dem ausbruch
seien
wir konnten jetzt mit einem der leiter
der koordinierungsgruppe corona im
landkreis garmisch-partenkirchen über
die durchgeführten tests sprechen
wir haben aktuell hier das hat ist es
jetzt nicht abschließend zu sagen jetzt
zum test anmelden und kommen wir haben
ein system in dem wir deutlich über 300
personen haben die sich heute angemeldet
habe zum testen
aber das eine ist die anmeldung und das
andere ist dann diejenigen die dann de
facto zum test kommen jetzt sind
letztendlich an die gesamte bevölkerung
des landkreises garmisch partenkirchen
beziehungsweise des garmisch
partenkirchen gerichtet im speziellen
und jüngere bevölkerung die kontakt zu
den jetzt die letzten tage positiv
getesteten personen glaubt haben können
jetzt sehen sie meinen kollegen jacob
mail er ist in garmisch partenkirchen
jakob was wissen wir denn über die super
sprecherin
ja es ist eine junge frau eine us
amerikanerin wie ich gerade erfahren
habe von dem vom landratsamt
sie arbeitet hier in einem hotel das dem
amerikanischen militär gehört was wir
noch wissen ist dass die junge frau ende
august aus einem griechenland urlaub
nach garmisch partenkirchen
zurückgekehrt ist
ob sie zu diesem zeitpunkt schon
infektiös war oder symptome gezeigt hat
ist noch unklar
sicher ist dass sie am 8 september
sicherheit testen lassen und obwohl sie
noch kein testergebnis hatte weiter hier
leben geführt hat und eben auch durch
die bars in garmisch partenkirchen
gezogen ist und dabei wohl auch einige
menschen wohnen angesteckt hat und auch
in ihrer arbeitsstelle auch menschen mit
dem corona virus infiziert hat genau das
wollte ich jetzt auch noch mal fragen
kannst du zusammenfassen was genau in
garmisch
passiert es gibt es da noch mehr
informationen als was du gerade schon
gesagt hast ja wie gesagt die junge dame
hat wohl ihr alkoholtest ergebnis nicht
abgewartet und ist dann stattdessen
einfach herum gezogen und hat weiter so
erzählt es das landratsamt weiter
gefeiert und hat eben da die menschen
angesteckt und auch ein teil ihrer
mitarbeiter oder mit ihrer kollegin und
jakob wie wird es denn jetzt weiter
gehen in garmisch also in der
gastronomie ist wohl die regelung jetzt
so dass die nächsten sechs tage die
gastronomie um 22 uhr schließen muss
zuvor konnten sie bis zum 2
12 uhr feiern jetzt ist erst mal um 22
uhr zapfenstreich
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren